in america 65 of our economy is driven
by
small business it's the essence of where
jobs are created and most of those are
family businesses you know you've got a
situation where a mother is suing a
daughter can you imagine can you imagine
what that's like and here we are in the
money court trying to peel the onion and
figure out what what really happened
here it's really about men women and
money
[Music]
yep he's rocking on the dock series but
i want to talk about tiege hanley i'm
really excited to have tiege hanley's a
sponsor of today's video they've helped
me start and maintain my skin care
routine by making the entire process
uncomplicated honestly it's the best
skin care system for guys like you and
me
i recommend you start with their level
one system which comes with all the
basics a daily face wash to get rid of
the dirt and grime on your skin it's
important a two times per week
exfoliating scrub to get rid of dead
skin cells
and am moisturizer with spf 20 because
you should always be protecting your
skin from the sun like i do it's sunny
out here and a pm moisturizer to help
your skin stay hydrated and healthy
throughout the night that way you wake
up looking fantastic yeah like i do my
favorite part about the tiege hanley is
that every box comes with an instruction
card that tells you when to use each
product how much to use and in what
order they really make the process of
achieving and maintaining your whole
look amazingly easy i've been using
their products for a little while now
and i'm hooked on them yeah it's true it
may sound weird but i look forward to my
morning and evening routines because i
just feel amazing and more confident
after using their products in addition
to amazing skin members of tiege hanley
get tons of benefits including 25 off
the retail price the ability to
customize your box and you can pause or
cancel anytime
and you get free us shipping if you're
outside the us they offer low cost
shipping to most countries
because t
is sponsoring today's video
they're offering my viewers a great deal
just click the first link in the
description and not only will you get
tiege hanley for the best possible price
you'll also get a free gift with your
first box
click that link and get started for just
twenty five dollars
yeah baby teach hanley so talk to us
about money court what is this concept
um you know
how did this idea come about and why did
you want to take on these kind of cases
well the genesis of the idea
is rather interesting because i get
pitched a lot of shows i have an agent
out in hollywood j surry's uta he hates
everything hates everything
it's always i hate it we're not doing it
i hate it i mean everything he's mr no
then one day a couple of years ago i'll
never forget it was 5 30. i like i like
to cook and i was in the kitchen cooking
i had my white song and phone rings it's
him and he he was giddy like a 12 year
old boy he was so excited he said i've
just heard a format that you were born
to do
and i want this deal and we should do it
and i said okay send me the script send
me the pitch deck you know he said no no
no
hang up the phone in two minutes mark
hoffman the ceo of cnbc is going to call
you
and pitch you himself and i went whoa
and he pitched it and
i immediately thought to myself why
didn't i think of that it's a fantastic
idea
you know and so i have to give him
credit you know there's a reason that
guy's been around so long everybody
every other television executive doesn't
last five years this guy's been around
forever he gets his hand dirty heads
dirty in the business he understands
production and creates shows so that's
the journey of that one it took a long
time to cast it a long time to really
distill the format we went through
countless hours of uh
you know casting uh to try to find the
right team
and that's not easy to do casting calls
take hours and hours and hours we're
doing in the middle of the pandemic but
we came across adam katie adam was
probably the last person we tested i'm
not kidding and and i knew right away
that she was going to be phenomenal and
katie was also towards the end so it
just shows you we went through a lot and
i think we put a great team together
okay so if i turn on my television and
i'm watching this what will i see tell
us tell us how the show works
you will recognize yourself
in each of these cases everybody has
a brother a sister a mother a father or
a relationship in business that this has
happened to in america 65 percent of our
economy is driven by
small business it's the essence of where
jobs are created and most of those are
family businesses and when you create a
business in a family and many of them
are very very successful they grow on to
do hundreds of millions in sales there's
always the tension between the business
and the interpersonal relationships of
family members or partners or brothers
or sisters or large corporations and
small vendors that are renting from them
or whatever it is
there's going to be a conflict and money
court attempts
to solve that because when you think
about what's happened in the last two
years in america particularly the last
year with the pandemic is there's a
massive log jam in the courts none of
these situations are getting resolved
and if you're in a business that has a
money dispute in it you're destroying
value for sure you've got to get that
resolved you've got to move on and
continue to grow and compete and that's
really what this is about i i think the
television itself is
very compelling to watch because it's a
human drama it's really about men women
and money yeah i mean that says it all
now is your ruling binding yes it is
this is arbitration so you are agreeing
to do this in lieu of going to court and
suing each other and frankly it's
probably a better outcome you know you
basically have to trust me as someone
who arbitrates the case
but what i find so intriguing as summed
up by one of the litigants said i don't
really like mr wonderful but i trust him
and so there you get there you get it
that's the essence of it he was willing
to trust my ruling and so i've got the
guidance of both ada and katie who are
in the legal system and can read
contract law and tell me what the law
says but i'm going to find for the
business in most cases because the
business is the source of wealth for
everybody so if you're suing each other
and you're destroying a business you're
destroying the relationship with your
customers your employees the people you
borrowed money from you're destroying
the whole thing and i'm going to always
try and solve for saving the business
above the interest of any one individual
now if i'm watching this show i'm not
only going to want to kind of see these
disputes play out and how you all decide
to rule as a as a panel as a court but i
also want to look for nuggets of you
giving business advice to you do you
find yourself doing that i mean people
are going to want to hear that from you
as well yes there is a segment that was
brought in uh as an idea to shoot in the
pilot where you asked kevin or ask mr
wonderful and i didn't think it was
going to work but i was wrong it really
worked and so i think we're going to be
incorporating that in the show going
forward it's a chance to answer a
question from anybody in the world and
give sound advice it's always about
business and i think you know i get that
every day in social media hundreds of
thousands of people sending me questions
all the time this is a way to answer
them for anyone watching this like you
said off the top you know everybody's
dealt with this for the most part in
some kind of way going into business
some kind of business with family
members close friends what kind of
advice would you give to anyone thinking
about doing that
i always tell people that if you're
going to go into business you have to be
able to fire your mother if needed you
always have to decide where you are in
the pecking order when you create a
business and you're taking your first
dollar you're no longer number one even
though you're the owner you're no longer
number one number one is your customers
number two are your employees number
three are the people you borrowed money
from or you've taken money from to build
your business with and then you're last
you're the last person you're at the
bottom but you're still the owner so you
have to serve all of these masters to be
successful you further complicate it
when you get family members working
together because they have to have
thanksgiving together you know they have
to be a family and a business partner
and that's very hard to do
you know you've got a situation where a
mother is suing a daughter can you
imagine can you imagine what that's like
and here we are in the money court
trying to peel the onion and figure out
what what really happened here because
that's that's something that that
relationship was broken a decade ago
something something happened and in
order to resolve the dispute you've got
to dig deep and in doing so that's a
very hard emotional journey for the
litigants and certainly for us as as
judges i mean it was brutal but
again you know i i i remember taping
that sequence and i remember taping it
live and i looked over to the right in
the middle of this you know
gut wrenching
you know case and everybody was glued to
the monitors just everybody in makeup
and lighting and all the grips everybody
just
glued and i thought to myself they're
not making television they're watching
it now
and that's when i knew we had a head and
people are going to get drawn into these
stories
they're very very compelling and you
will recognize yourself in them you will
see yourself in there you seem pretty
comfortable in this judge's chair do you
ever consider going into law in any way
law and politics are two things i've
looked at and i won't try that again
very very expensive you know you can
think you're good at something you have
to stay in your in your uh in your lane
in your column you know you have to you
have to know what you're good at i don't
think i want to be a politician i don't
think i want to be a judge but i've been
very happy to arbitrate business
disputes because that's what i do all
day long and have been doing that for
decades and you posted some fun behind
the scenes stuff from the new season of
shark tank have you been saying yes to
lots of people
i have you know it's been interesting
people are intrigued by the show they're
all waiting for the premiere i get it
making a show like this is very time
consuming but also lots of fun meeting
new partners like katie and ada i mean
i've worked with all kinds of people on
television but i know with certainty you
need the chemistry
it has to be there and that was our
challenge for a whole year we were
trying to cast the right team and i'm
very fortunate i've always been able to
work with you know the top of the
top of the of the of the pile producers
and mark brunette and clay newball these
are multi emmy award winners same with
eric schatz who's show running this show
denise conte who has now taken over
prime time at cnbc they were all part of
that alchemy you know we spent countless
hours together
looking at casting opportunities
deciding on format ideas just it's real
it's really tough if you like that video
wait do you see my next one don't forget
to click right over here and subscribe